hallo ich an freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren texture
pack vorstellungen heute habe ich mir
das texture pack rap kraft ausgesucht
und ich zeige euch da jetzt mal so ein
paar items ein paar mops und dann läuft
mir da auch gleich ein villages bild
viel spaß so ihr fragt euch nun bestimmt
wo befinden wir uns hier und zwar ist
das hier eine arena
die habe ich mir aus dem internet aus
dem planet minecraft forum irgendwo
runtergeladen ich glaube von ipod mail
ist jeder von einem youtube erhalt und
die habe ich ziemliche modifiziert also
ich hab hier ziemlich viele items or
angebaut wie zum beispiel glas dann habe
ich hier eine kiste hingestellt hier so
ein paar nutzer teams also in wien
crafting tables ein paar ärzte hätten da
sind per holzsorten die allgemein habe
ich bäume gras dann village eingesetzt
da oben befindet sich wolle die habe ich
dorthin platziert hier so ein paar
komische sachen und hier unten habe ich
noch so ein paar mobbing gepflanzt und
einen kürbis
naja egal jedenfalls ist das die neue
texture pack arena in der ich euch immer
die aktuellen texte packs vorstellen
werde
die ihr mir in die kommentare schreiben
könnt da könnt ihr außerdem auch auf
euren minecraft skin in die kommentare
schreiben den ich dann eventuell mal
irgendwann benutzen werde in einer
anderen vorstellung oder so könnt ihr
immer mal machen
übrigens heißt das nicht dass ich immer
den sieg von allerdings gehen von einem
nutzer zum beispiel heute habe ich
meinen eigenen an
einfach weil ich da als damit ganz kurz
ändern kann also wenn das sieht man beim
einzigen halt gut wenn er in welche
sachen an hat das sieht man waren uns
geht es nicht so gut
egal jedenfalls würde ich sagen wir
fangen direkt anderen mit der
vorstellung und zwar das texture pack
wie schon im intro erwähnt red kraft im
wdr 3 d kraft das ist eigentlich dass
die volltext speck aber einer viel
höheren auflösung also das ist 128 x 128
ihr seht dass hier irgendwie dabei den
stein da sind viel mehr pixel als sonst
im echten minecraft default weinstein zb
so so in dem maßstab so und hier ist er
halt so also das sieht man bei der kiste
besonders gut finde ich da sieht man
richtig dieser ganzen rillen und so das
finde ich auf jeden fall sehr
interessant wäre vielleicht
so sieht man es ganz gut ja so sieht man
es ganz gut also das ist halt wirklich
so dass die volltexte pack einfach nur
in der anderen variante dass das ein
paar sachen wirklich mehr gepixelt
wurden allet allerdings ihr seht das
hier so zum beispiel die schienen sind
wirklich 128 und das hier ist noch
normale minecraft textur ganz einfach
dieses texture pack schon nicht ganz
fertig uns war es das bisher 90 prozent
fertig das ist auch der grund warum die
das schwein zum beispiel was jeder hat
gesehen habt ja nicht gepixelt ist aber
das huhn ist zum beispiel schon fertig
das seht ihr dann der wolle an dem hund
bleibt verstehen so da seht ihr dass das
ist auch schon in einer ganz anderen
variante als also einen ganz anderen
auflösung als zum beispiel diese schwein
naja also so sehen die verschiedenen
holzsorten aus dass dir dieses häufig
extrem geil und dieses holz also dies
dunkle das sieht auf jeden fall viel
viel besser aus wenn eine runde button
sieht auf jeden fall viel viel besser
aus in diesem text speck als im default
expect und ihr seht euch schon das
komplette menüs ein bisschen weißer und
hier ein paar items die ich euch auch
zeigen wollte ich das schwert hatten
ziemlich starken rand was ich nicht ganz
so toll finde
allgemein alle items aber hier die
pfeile animation so für dich e mail
school der fall es war relativ stumpf
ich find's ganz cool und wir schon
gezeigt das hühnchen sieht so aus also
das pitching gepixelt die können jetzt
sterben stirbt so sondern haben wir
wieder fleisch zum beispiel wurde noch
nicht rein gepixelt feder auch noch
nicht also ist er noch wirklich alles
antun so sehen die ganzen - hier aus
wenn ich da irgendwie darauf zugreifen
muss ein auge rein stimmt geändert
westhofen gäste optisch könnte ich nach
einsätzen ist wusste ich gar nicht
stimmt ich brauche keine war zurück gut
dass ihr sind so ein paar sachen wie
testens bestens wurden gemacht tnt wird
auch gemacht wie wurde eigentlich alle
gemacht dass auch wenn man es hier nicht
so stark sieht das wird schon ein
bisschen anders gemacht die teile ja
auch und vor allem bei der wolle finde
ich es ganz cool und zwar sieht man das
nur bei der weißen wolle die wurde auch
verbessert und die wolle sieht viel viel
geiler aus von weit weg sieht genauso
aus wie vorher bei wenn man dran zum
ziel schon pixel besser aus und da ist
also ein kreis rum den sieht man warte
ich vorher zu gehen
hier sieht man so den kreis um den
holzblock rum das finde ich auf jeden
fall sehr interessant dass es in
minecraft auch kreise gibt
also so sehen treppen aus und hier
dekkers das auch ganz interessant wird
auch schon fertig gemacht das sieht
alles mehr ausübt dass mehr konturen
hier das bett wird auch gemacht also ein
bisschen mehr wollte ich weil ich mich
warm und ich finde wenn man sich solche
steine anguckt sieht das aus als hätte
das halt alles mehr konturen also eher
das war es auch schon mit dieser
vorstellung ich hab euch nun die
entscheidendste blöcke gezeigt hier noch
hier blumen und so wird auch noch nicht
gemacht dass hier wird allerdings schon
gemacht das wiederum auch als es noch
nicht komplett fertig aber ich finde
dieses sixpack extrem geil weil es
einfach so dass default ding ist und das
ist default einfach besser ja besser
dargestellt also auf jeden fall detail
reicher ist auch in der bearbeitung
kennen noch nicht ganz so viele hatte
ich damals schon beim letzten mal
benutzt und naja also meinen
entscheidender letzter score ist neun
von zehn diamanten warum nur neun warum
ein diamant abzug das einfach weil es
halt noch nicht komplett fertig ist und
das ist bisher auch nur vereins punkt
2.5 draußen also wenn ich irgendwie
jetzt ins menü geht von den text schrieb
ex wo ich eigentlich gar nicht eingehen
weil wir das bei mir letzter zeit ein
bisschen hart ist es bisher glaube ich
nur für 1.2 punkt 5 draußen bzw vereins
punkt 3.2 immer noch nicht fertig und es
wird wahrscheinlich auch erst dann
fertig sein die als punkt 4000 sind dann
muss er wieder update muss jetzt ein
bisschen doof dann gelaufen aber ich
werde erst mal sagen jetzt was von
dieser text app tech review von rap
kraft wie immer wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über einen daumen
hoch freuen bzw allgemein eine bewertung
und ja ihr könnt mir auch ins kinn in
die kommentare schreiben und dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal